yes to bring some positivity back into
the podcast we got spell
we got sent something super special this
week did we i guess we did
bring it out onto the table on the
subreddit and the twitter's
this post blew up that somebody made a a
nice little uh quilt for us actually i
think it's actually quite large
that is large um there was also a letter
included from shelby i believe yeah
shelby from shelby yeah we did we did
reading we're not going to read it out
on the podcast
but uh it was uh that boy opened
so i think uh there's different gifts
for different people oh i mean i
i assume this is yeah this is this is
the main while you guys are opening that
i'll just i'll just go ahead and explain
uh we don't have a po box and we
probably won't
um i've had a po box before and although
it is great receiving stuff
it's also equally frustrating figuring
out what the [ __ ] to do with all the
stuff that you get sent
i have so much food go stale on me so
much food go bad
yeah i i feel like opening a po box is
kind of like
you know like opening your first discord
right it's not it's it sounds it sounds
great in theory
but then when you get to a point where
you get sense too much stuff that it's
manageable yeah that's when it becomes
like it becomes a second job basically
like super grateful that people are
wondering like that doesn't mean we're
not grateful
we know you guys want to send us stuff
and everything like that
um just at this point we just want less
things to manage you know what i mean
but nothing to worry about but like when
we see something cool like this
like get posted or something we just we
just we just wanted we just want to see
holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] that's huge oh it's the wrong
way around
holy [ __ ] that's gargantuan audio users
can take that out of context if you like
wow that is audio users what you're
looking at right now is just a giant
[ __ ] trash taste quilt oh my god
that's actually amazing what the [ __ ]
shelby what the [ __ ] but thank you
shelby so much
thank you oh my god so much holy [ __ ]
shout out to shelby
here as well he rings i believe they
were i'll find the sharpie's message
yes so the key rings are uh for meleen
you and i
there is a a a key ring for meleen which
is the pink one
a silver one for me green one for gone
[Music]
cnm oh okay so there's your c
fantastic well you're too nice shelby
thank you thank you
so much thank you very much episode of
trash taste by the way
um we're winding down now uh oh it's a
humongous thing
was it really oh it's got my it's got my
little uh
[ __ ] she's got both of the ducky macros
i own in thailand
and the glasses are here i have the rose
that's so cool
oh my god this is amazing can i open
yours mainly
thank you so much that's so [ __ ] cool
it's gonna be a rose
god damn some people are too nice man
yeah so this is obviously this is
honestly one of the coolest
oh man is pink with like cat ears
really loves cats by the way